Peter King you can checkout Pete's NFL
column football morning in America every
Monday exclusively on NBC sports.com
Pete in attendance for the Chargers
Ravens yesterday Pete good morning how
are you Dan how are you doing today I'm
a little fired up over a couple things
you know the Cody parky thing and you
know that we love to blame and it's it's
an easy story to write and you know the
Bears didn't lose because of him and I
think that sometimes we're unfair when
it comes down to these one-time-only
situations and you know so I felt bad
for him so I think I think the one thing
and look I'm part of the media madness I
named him I go to the week you ought to
be able to make a 43-yard field goal I
get that but I also think that you know
I think philosophically much much much
bigger picture why do we watch sports
okay well we want sports because there's
a chance that you could win there's a
chance you could lose you know nothing
other than the old extra point really is
is just about automatic and you know you
don't watch sports because you know
what's going to happen you watch sports
because you don't know what's going to
happen and so you know if a guy misses a
43-yard field goal yeah he probably
should have made the field goal but the
bottom line in this is that it is a
sports event you're witnessing this you
you should be able to have the maturity
to look at it and be really really angry
and not go crucify this kid for for
missing a kick and so look I mean you
know he deserves blame you know either
for not getting a kick high enough or or
whatever yeah but let's let's all simmer
down a little bit about about nailing
the guy to the cross for crying out loud
you were in attendance for the Chargers
Ravens what did you make of that game
from start to finish you know I thought
one of the best playoff coaching jobs
I've seen is by Gus Bradley the
defensive
coordinator of the Chargers who wouldn't
the Anthony Lynn at the beginning of
last week the head coach of the Chargers
and said look coach I we we we didn't do
a great job on last time and nobody's
been doing a great job
playing them conventionally so you know
the Chargers were already had some
injuries at at the linebacker position
Gus Bradley basically said I want to
play seven linebackers I want our
safeties to drop down and play
linebackers and we're going to play all
of our corners in the game and then one
of funny things is at the end of every
game you get this thing from the PR
staff of whatever game you're at and
it's called the official NFL play by
play and I looked at it in the first
play of the game for the San Diego
Chargers all the guys on there our DB is
a four defensive lineman it's the
craziest thing I've ever seen and and so
that was a really smart thing to do
because from the first snap of the game
when Derwin James was there spying Lamar
jacks and nailing him for one yard loss
you just sort of knew that this was
going to be a different game now I think
they played extremely well on defense
and the Ravens almost came back but it
never really felt like they were going
to come back you know and look large
accents got a long way to go in the
passing game to make people fear him
throwing the ball and that's what he's
gonna have to work on this offseason
would you put in Flacco at any point
yesterday I probably would have late in
the third quarter you know you could see
that that there was no question that
Harbaugh was sort of you know on the
edge of a sword there but you know I
think that that Harbaugh basically said
okay look you know Franco hasn't played
in two months he's not going to be able
to move around well against this
voracious defense so I think his thought
was these guys are killing Lamar Jackson
they're gonna they sacked them seven
times as it turns out and if like I
think he thought was gonna be too much
of a sitting duck Flacco is not back
next year is John Harbaugh back in
Baltimore my gut feeling is yes but I
don't think anybody knows that right now
Dan because it's going to be a very
interesting question when Steve
bisciotti realized that John Harbaugh
and any might he very well might sign a
contract but I think this Pete Carroll
contract in is going to have some
bearing I think the Pete Carroll
contract is going to have some bearing
on on what happens to Harbaugh the rumor
eleven million dollar a year contract
now there are eight coaches in the
league including Harvey will make at
least eight million dollars between
eight and whatever Belichick makes
twelve fifteen I don't even know what it
is you know unlike players contracts
coaches contracts are not publicized so
I think that Harbaugh rightfully so
would look at Pete Carroll's deal and
said hey I've been here longer I've won
more we've each won a Super Bowl
we better be talking and again I have
not talked to John Harbaugh about this
I'm just trying to read into who
Harbaugh is he's a tremendously
competitive person and I think he would
look at at at that contract and say you
know let's start it eleven million for
me to talking to Peter King you can read
his column every Monday it's a football
morning in America you can see that
exclusively on NBC sports.com couple
other things here with the Eagles
advancing and Nick Foles Nick Foles and
how available is Nick Foles going to be
or how costly is he going to be for a
team that is a fantastic question and
then I wrote this this morning somebody
wrote me a letter and I answer email in
my column
every week and somebody wrote to me and
said what basically what's the endgame
with Falls can he win enough to win this
job and I said look I talked to somebody
last week it was very very close to this
situation and who said that that he
thinks that the people and authority of
the Eagles should go to Nick Foles and
ask him this question you know you
you're not like every other quarterback
yeah and you've seen what happens when
you have a chance to go to a bad team
because obviously he knows what happens
when he went to the Rams and they were
bad it was a nightmare he almost quit
football so I I wonder whether the
Eagles will attempt at least for one
more year to make him Mariano Rivera who
the e or make him the highest-paid
relief pitcher in football
and again he's got an option next year a
team option for 20.6 million they could
keep them if they wanted to but I think
the understanding is I've always thought
that if Nick Foles really wanted to go
that they probably wouldn't stand in his
way
but who knows they may decide that we've
got some value here that we'd like to
trade I think it's very much up in the
air and I think the Eagles are very glad
they don't have to decide this until
after the season and you have this
reversed where you have your backup
making a whole lot more than your
starter cuz whence I believe is gonna
make seven hundred thousand next year so
normally it's the other way around and
you have that luxury but I'm wondering
Nick Foles is in you know improving his
trade value with every performance and
it feels like if you're Jacksonville or
something you know some other team you
might be going you know what maybe maybe
that's our bridge quarterback for the
next couple of years we can bring him in
so I'm kind of missing his being I'll
tell you this Jacksonville is the
perfect team absolutely perfect team for
Nick Foles if he were to actually move
on because they have already made
defense they sort of had a blip on their
screen this year if I were the Jaguars I
would be putting all my eggs in Nick
Foles basket and not Mae
not just as a bridge quarterback guys
just going to be 30 years old next year
and again you know you'll see what
happens maybe it'll turn out that he
should be a backup quarterback or you
you know maybe maybe it'll turn out that
you know that if somebody shows so much
faith in him that he that he won't be
what he was in Philadelphia that it was
just magic in Philadelphia in the
support system and Doug Peterson and
last year Frank Wright
so we'll see but of all the teams that
I've thought of the best overall is the
Jacksonville Jaguars for him if I would
have told you in September the Colts are
gonna be a real tough out in the post
season
what would you say I'd say you would
have been crazy
I thought the Indianapolis Colts were
definitely definitely on the right path
I named Chris Ballard as my executive of
the Year this year his draft was
unbelievably good he might have gotten
the Defensive Rookie of the Year in the
second round from South Carolina State
he stepped in led the league in tackles
as a rookie I talked to Perry as Leonard
a couple of weeks ago and he said hey I
thought this was just gonna be a
learning year for me you know and they
put him in the games and he just they
never took him out and then you know
taking offensive lineman twice in the
first two rounds you know if Ballard
knew what this team needed it needed a
suit of armor to be build around the
Andrew Luck and it needed some defensive
playmakers that's what that's what
they've got and I I but I have to tell
you I'm totally blown away by the very
quick transformation you know it's why
it's why there's so much hope every year
the Indianapolis called - the perfect
example of why every July you know it
starts to get late July early August you
start to look at your team hey maybe we
got a chance this year who in the world
thought the Colts would be on a 10 to 10
in one run right now I certainly didn't
what do you make of the Cowboys and that
performance against Seattle I think that
that was the perfect game for them you
know a month or so ago Jerry Jones
starts talking about how Jack needs to
run
yeah dad picked two absolutely perfect
times to take off with the ball and he's
such you know he is he's not the best
runner of the quarterbacks in football
by any means but he is one of the
smartest runners that you'll see because
he knows exactly when to go and when to
stay and I just I've got great
admiration for what he did and to me I
wrote this in my column Ezekiel Elliott
has now convinced me that he could play
in any era of football he's such a smart
football player in in my opinion you
knowing when to stay in bounds no one
went to go for more yards you know when
to you you know wouldn't went it went to
say die and I do I really think that
he's the kind of fast physical back that
you know again I and this is a difficult
thing for me to say because I think Jim
Brown's the best running back of all
time he's got a lot of traits of Jim
Brown in my opinion as far as being
physical but being fast at the same time
I I just I really love him as a football
player and I think they were that was a
really good match for them against
Seattle because Seattle's defense is
good but it's not it's it isn't great
and and I think that was a good team for
them to play in the first playoff game
scoring was down Pete is that just an
aberration or do you think that's what
we're going to be seeing here after the
referendum on the future of football
after the chiefs and rams and that was
everybody had to find their Sean McVeigh
feels like we're back to what we are
normally back to at this time of the
year and that's running the football
playing defense well you know the is I
wrote this morning teams
average 23.5 points a game during the
regular season this year and it was down
to 18 point 1 in the first round of the
playoffs and look Dan it's four games
you know I can't I can't tell you what's
going to happen but you know some pretty
potentially explosive teams are playing
this week everybody discounts
Patriot's their fourth in the NFL and
scoring this year again they were well
over 400 points so you know the Chargers
can score you know in the Saints
obviously even though they had a slump
at the end of the season there they're a
good scoring team so in the Rams
obviously I think I think it's more of a
blip but I do think except for the
Ravens you know they the really
excellent all-around defensive teams
show up you know with this at this time
of year and I mean except for the Ravens
Ravens are one of those but they lost I
think because they just couldn't get
anything going on offense good stuff is
always Pete and have a great week thanks
for talking and talk to you soon that's
a Peter King NFL column football morning
in America every Monday exclusively on
NBC sports.com for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]